What would you think if Cristina Fernández
returned to control and dominate Argentina?
Could something like this even happen?
Dear viewers, last April 2019 a survey caused
a political earthquake in Argentina.
An earthquake that also had significant economic
consequences.
You see, the consultancy firm Isonomia, a
company that actually has close ties to the
government and has been working with Macri
for several years, noted that if the next
Argentinian elections reached the second round
– the first round will be held on October
27th and November 24th for the second round
– if that happened, Cristina Fernandez de
Kirchner’s hypothetical candidacy would
win over the current president, Mauricio Macri.
Right now, poor economic performance is causing
support for President Macri to plummet.
Inflation is extremely high, tariff increases
and the sense that nothing has really changed
on a political level, has caused Mauricio
Macri’s popularity to drop like a rock.
But just a second folks.
On May 18th, a second political earthquake
shook Argentina.
For the first time in history, a vice presidential
candidate named her choice for president.
You can not change a country only with a good
government, in its three branches of power.
To change a country you need good government
and a good society.)
Cristina Fernandez made her decision to stand
for election public... but not as number one,
as number two, as a vice presidential candidate.
Former Argentine President Kirchner Seeks
Return to Power, as Vice President.
New York Times)
You heard that correctly.
In the end, the Kirchnerist candidate will
be Alberto Fernández, Néstor Kirchner’s
Chief of Staff.
He also held that post in Cristina’s government
for one year.
I’ve asked Alberto Fernandez to lead the
formula that we will run together, he as the
presidential candidate and I as vice-president,
to participate in the upcoming primary, open,
simultaneous and mandatory elections”.
Cristina Fernández de Kirchner)
Folks, faced with this leadership scenario
at least three questions surface:
The first is easy; Why on earth did Kirchner
decide to do this?
This takes time, effort, perseverance with
the objectives.
Nobody can do things in two or three years)
Well... let's say that the answer has a lot
to do with her currently good popularity.
As we’ve seen, for the first time since
2015, several polls placed Kirchner as the
winner for not only the first but also the
second round.
And in the meantime address all friends, colleagues,
officials who have some dollars in fixed term
deposits.
You Moreno, right?)
Now, just a second.
The same forecasts also indicated a high number
of undecided votes.
And, folks, this was very clear to election
experts: the fear of Kirchner’s return,
once it’s election time, could shift many
votes back to the current ruling party.
However, with this decision, two things happen:
on the one hand, fear of the former president
is somewhat diluted; she’s no longer a presidential
candidate.
And on the other, the new duo could reach
voters that Kirchner alone would never have
reached.
Allow me to explain: Alberto Fernandez’s
candidacy puts Regenerationism on the table,
his discourse is more moderate and there’s
the idea that the new duo would apply different
policies to those implemented by Cristina
in the past.
Which is essential to achieve victory.
Because of course, if you want to win the
elections, you can’t just count on your
stalwarts.
you have to convince new voters while also
taking care not to mobilize your rival’s
vote.
As Vice President, Cristina contributes all
her electoral strength without causing excessive
fear.
So, based on this scenario, folks, the former
president’s decisions multiply her options
of returning to power.
And that’s what she cares about the most.
Not just because she likes power, but because
she needs to maintain the rights that go with
being a high level politician in order to
survive.
Cristina Fernández de Kirchner needed to
participate in the elections due to a legal
situation, which we already discussed here
on VISUALPOLITIK.
The ex-president has ten prosecutions and
five preventive detention requests.
Folks, the only reason she isn’t already
in jail is because she still has her senator
privileges.
The Senate, which is dominated by the Peronists,
has not withdrawn them.
So, the first question, why did she decide
to run as Vice President? has been answered.
The second question is, can this pairing really
win the elections?
I mean, Are we serious?! after the previous
government’s terrible results and all the
corruption?
“They extend Cristina Kirchner’s processing
in notebook scandal,
Judge Claudio Bonadio considered her a “co-author
of five other acts of bribery” and raised
the embargo against her to 80 million pesos.”
Profile)
Well… yeah.
At least that’s what the voter intention
studies say.
Surveys such as those of Analía del Franco
or Ricardo Rouvier y Asociados placed Kirchner
ahead with an advantage of 9.5 and 4 points
respectively.
We can also find surveys, even more important
ones, which put Macri in the lead, but by
an increasingly smaller margin.
And of course, now with the new formula many
of the fears of Kirchnerism have diluted,
particularly because Alberto Fernández himself
was very critical of the former President:
“It’s hard to find something virtuous
in Cristina’s last mandate”.
Alberto Fernández, 2015)
"She even said that Germany was worse than
us in terms of poverty, maintained that the
stocks didn’t exist and that inflation didn’t
matter to the end, that’s denial, a stubborn,
sometimes absurd denial" Alberto Fernández,
2015)
That is, how, overnight, the Kirchner-created
formula can be seen as a sign of change.
Something like...
“Hey, we learned from our mistakes, but
our intentions were always good, now we’ve
got it figured out and the important thing
isn’t a person’s job title but the project”.
Incredible, huh?
Now, let's be clear.
you can’t really say that this is a surprising
or exceptional scenario, not at all.
It’s part of a fairly predictable trend.
Macri has gone from leading the polls in January
to drawing with Cristina in March and then
to lagging behind her in April.
As incredible as it may seem, according to
the polls, Christina’s support hasn’t
stopped rising.
The former president has gone from being a
headache to Peronism, which wanted to revamp
its image to becoming its best wild card,
a chance of recovering the government of the
republic.
At the moment it seems like the evolution
of the economy will be the decisive factor.
If things weren’t so bad, perhaps even Macri
could get enough support from the undecided
voters to remain in the Casa Rosada.
The problem?
As things stand, improving the economic situation
in the short term seems quite complicated.
And that’s Kirchner’s best card right
now, one more slip and Macri is sent to the
bench.
You see, the Argentine economy is going through
a very, very fragile timet.
Inflation in March was 4.7%.
That’s the rate for one month, not one year.
2019 could close with a 35 to 50% inflation
rate; the peso just keeps falling against
the dollar, stocks aren’t doing well either,
the country’s risk is now over 1000 points
and the country is still in recession.
Folks, the race between Macri and Kirchner’s
hypothetical candidacies had become a race
to be the least bad in the eyes of public
opinion.
And no, this is not a criticism, it’s simply
fact:
Both Cristina Fernández de Kirchner and Mauricio
Macri are reaping very negative evaluations
from the Argentinians.
In the case of the current president, according
to surveys, up to 84% of Argentinians have
a negative opinion of him.
On the other hand, though it may seem incredible
given all the scandals, the former president’s
data are somewhat better, but not that much.
In her case, the negative opinion score is
76%
But now with the arrival of Alberto Fernández
things are different.
The new candidate is less "tainted" than the
former president.
I mean, I don’t think that instead of going
back five years with president Cristina, we
go back fifteen to something similar to Néstor,
lowering Cristina and raising Alberto Fernández
means a substantial change for the economy
or for people's lives.
I don’t think so.)
So, the third and most important question
based on what we’ve seen would be: What
consequences would the victory of Alberto
Fernández and Cristina Fernández de Kirchner
have and on what kind of public policies would
they bet?
Well, it turns out we don’t even have to
wait until October to start answering.
You see, the mere fact that Kirchner became
a favorite in the polls has already made all
international investors very, very nervous.
Well, perhaps it’s better to say, even more
nervous than they already were.
And that has translated into a new drop of
the peso against the dollar.
Which may have also fueled the idea of ​​this
new and surprising formula.
Now, why so much nervousness?
Because it was assumed that Cristina’s return
to power would mean a return to the same ultra-interventionist
policies and tons of public spending, as in
the previous stage.
Ok, Macri didn’t lead to any great change
either, but if Cristina returned, any possibility
of Argentina changing – and don’t tell
me it doesn’t need a change – would go
out the window.
The simple fact that Kirchner took the lead
in the polls fueled investors' fear of a new
and upcoming Argentine default.
And, folks, that makes things even worse...
to such an extent that even some analysts,
such as Carlos Malamud, have warned of a forthcoming
exchange run – that is, the peso will sink
even more because everyone will want to get
rid of that currency – if Kirchnerism continues
to improve its chances of getting back in
power.
In any case, regardless of whether Macri wins
or loses the elections, Argentina’s current
situation is complicated.
The government will have to return a whopping
34 billion dollars in 2020, in a context of
severe economic recession and with a peso
that is depreciating at full speed.
Argentina is at a crossroads: its debt in
dollars is huge, accounting for almost 90%
of the GDP, a figure that won’t stop increasing
due to the peso’s collapse.
The more the peso falls, the greater the burden
of the debt in dollars for the Argentine economy.
The probability that Argentina will not succeed
in paying this debt within one presidential
term is high.
Yes, the probability of default is high, but
it isn’t a fact.
The situation is not yet irreversible and
fortunately it seems that almost all political
leaders are clear on this.
The fact that Cristina has decided to run
as Vice President in Alberto Fernández’s
candidacy could be a good test.
After all, as we’ve already seen, Alberto
Fernández was very critical of Cristina Fernández’s
management.
However...
Argentina does need a total change of course.
And, to be frank, Alberto Fernández doesn’t
seem so committed to leading that change given
his current running mate is the former president.
Don’t you think?
And folks, that is what leads us directly
to this video’s main question:
Will the new government, be it Macri, Fernandez
or any other candidate, be willing to carry
out that massive change?
Leave your answer in the comments as well
as in the survey.
So I really hope you enjoyed this video, please
hit like if you did, and don’t forget to
subscribe for brand new videos.
Don’t forget to check out our friends at
the Reconsider Media Podcast - they provided
the voiceover in this episode.
Also, this channel is possible because of
Patreon, and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting
our mission of providing independent political
coverage.
And as always, I’ll see you in the next
video.